[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
écoutez bien ça va être très simple on
va jouer au tir à l'arc
vous allez tout jouer vous avez passé
chacun votre tour
à chaque fois la flèche qui aura gagné
aura le droit de casser et d'éliminer
une des autres flèches au hockey ou
encore usher le dernier jouera contre
moi ok si le dernier gagnent on réalise
son rêve
si le dernier père si je gagne donc je
réaliserai le rêve de luiz qui est avec
nous en ligne salut louise bonjour
louise mais je t'entends hyper bien
c'est la première fois qu'on a réussi à
passer un coup de fil au septième
échelon à vous c'est génial et toi
n'hésite pas à mettre la flèche denture
mais ça va je la dois derrière l'autre
ne m'était complètement cinglé si louise
michel et c'est quoi ton rêve je rêve de
passer des vacances au soleil de
houssard villepin une île je sais pas
thual au mexique de ta fille ce serait
le rêve collait bien pépitos pour ça bon
si tu gagnes pas si je vais jouer pour
toi si je gagne tu pars au mexique
d'accord d'accord louise attaque je vais
vous dire elle tous les rêves des
chroniqueurs
car à chaque fois votre rêve sur a brisé
une fois qu'on aura cassé votre flèche
mathieu son rêve c'est assez assister
tout un week-end au grand prix de f1 de
monaco
valérie sait nager avec des dauphins aux
bahamas à obama vous allez manger du
gala dans la loge savalou et attend ça
d'accord mais d'accord ou non me daquo
je réalisais votre yann agathe ses
shoots et en parachute depuis un avion
c'est mieux très bien merci
jean-michel faire un trajet en avion
dans un cockpit avec une hôtesse avec
une hôtesse je réaliserai votre rêve
maxime s'est joué dans une série à une
série télé ah ça c'est le moins chaud je
réaliserai votre rêve où il dit isabelle
c'était un match le badmington contre le
champion de france a su rivaliser en
france elie contre vous passé le choc
joe réaliser notre rêve
géraldine sait faire les championnats du
monde de poker à las vegas je les fais
cet été je réaliserai votre ep
ah la la jean-luc s'est monté sur scène
à new york mme jean luc tu le mérites
on l'a vu vendredi soir sur ses 8 il a
cartonné aujourd'hui il montera sur
scène à new york
allez vas-y a dit bien fait mal mais
elle est bien loin de belhadj du feu et
plus ont ils écrit
boni et vous le bandeau va très bien
merci c'est un nouveau style vraiment
aller maxime koenig tissu on y va céder
la place à celui qui me lisent rade fake
dont qui brisera de rêve attention à
gâteau pond way le pantalon va très bien
à long oui en effet à bientôt pour la
numéro pour l'instant c'est la numéro
une sartec des services et qui sont mort
à walla les ans l'autre l'autre ça et ça
va pas du tout le look est tout en bas
qu'il est lourd la nouvelle je peux plus
le voir
[Applaudissements]
à
c'est jean luc godard jean luc et
matthieu aller et jean michel maire
voilà les voici
non et nos amis est il mort là il mordre
et nous aurions il mort se combler garde
sans délai sur les 18 possibles
mais quelle banane donc géraldine et
maxime qui dit vrai vous êtes éliminé
par attention on repart pour un tour les
chéris mais qu'il est lourd jean luc
lemoine du coup dans sa gamme qui était
sa gamme qui était le sien à l'hygiène
donc je vais chez le maire on sent bien
à temps jean-michel twelve encore deux
flèches aux ailes première mettez-vous
de côté si vous plaisir et mettez-vous
de côté là bas merci non non yahya yahya
agathe agathe
malheureusement non pour l'instant c'est
le jour jean-michel zahia vexé que nous
la fait mourir de lèche incroyable il va
décidément quand ça veut pas ça veut pas
le cut après ce sera jean luc
et naïm nom jean luc lemoine tension
jean luc lemoine
j'étais bon essai on voit ce qu'elle
était magnifique mais je rappelle qu'une
inaction collet est une flèche éliminé
atego cheikh sharif s'est jamais encore
c'est encore jean louis mathieu isabelle
et les bus et les options très dur à
battre
ouais non il était dans la merde
il est trop fort attention dans une
vérité mérite médaille ou non mettre à
poil trop bas je la sens pas du tout bon
la sorte le pantalon certes le porter
mais la version sommes en direct bien
sûr mais c'est encore jean michel maire
de filles alors attention vous éliminez
irex valérie bénaïm valérie bénaïm
agathe et ce sera jean luc lemoine
contre jean michel mr la finale il
il ya trop de pression oh la la c'est
moderne et ses actes date de la série
créé l'égalité jean luc et plus près il
n'y a pas égalité
c'est jean luc lemoine qui est le plus
près mérite de lui me ronan thomas
savage et casimir est d'accord jean luc
lemoine et en finale messieurs
et où j'entendais ou des mots du genre
de crime et noms d'oiseaux à mannheim à
malte 3 mais jamal sapera zhihui on
lâche rien non au merzer aux couëts luiz
pour l'instant rien zéro pour toi les
civils à la longue où il est un peu jean
luc pailler concentré si jamais cette
plaque ce sera fait les pattes de poulet
ou quoi mais si jamais cette flèche ce
sera terminé
c'est gagner à chérie tu pars au mexique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]